we begin with that breaking news this
afternoon crews on the scene of a deadly
house fire in the far east part of town
near desert and hollywood
the clark county fire department saying
one person has passed away
thank you for joining us at four o'clock
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm denise valdez
that house fire prompting a pretty big
response from firefighters this
afternoon
eight news now reporter erko mana
joining us now live from the scene in
orko i know you just arrived shortly uh
can you tell us what happened
well not yet denise and kirsten fire
crews here are still trying to figure
out
what started this fire the second floor
is completely gutted it's out now but
the damage to the home is pretty
substantial
firefighters found the person who died
on the second floor and again crews are
here
still investigating now here's a better
look at the damage to the second floor
of the home
the clark county fire department says
when crews first got here around 12 15
this afternoon
they saw heavy flames in the upstairs
area firefighters aggressively attacked
the fire and searched the second story
that's when they found the one person
dead inside the home fire crews were
able to extinguish the fire within about
20 minutes and then spent a while
putting out hot spots
several engines were called out to what
officials are describing
as a high level fire metro police is
also out here investigating but we're
told
that that standard procedure anytime
there's a deadly fire
now right now there's not an estimated
cost of the damage
and also we again are still waiting to
hear from officials about
the cause of the fire and the cause of
the person who died so stay with eight
news now
both on air and online for the latest
updates for now reporting live from the
far east valley
orca mana 8 news now